how's it going reject nation we are
going to watch today
willem dafoe as joker this video got
sent to me a couple weeks ago by a few
people on instagram and i saw this
recent week tyrone magnus covered it as
well and so i went well
tyrone did it we gotta do it every video
on this channel that we've ever done is
all based off of did tyrone cover it
first cause if he did then we have the
go-ahead to do it unless we can do it
better and then we don't
never never never never and every video
that we've done that you're like but
i've been on tyrone's channel
why doesn't he have a reaction to that
up he deleted it after he saw how much
better
our video was why we can't do those
anymore just text me back tyrone
he blocked me i can't even leave a
comment on his channel now
no i'm just kidding he doesn't even know
my name i don't know where this bit came
from
all right oh yeah this comes from the
channel muhammad x
akraf
not tyrone magnus
i've seen concept art months ago but
this is different
this is a video of really emotion i have
gaps
i have gaps in my teeth
people have suggested that i fix them oh
i like my gaps detail as my father used
to say
son your teeth are
air cooled
gaps are openness possibility
room to save her this is great effects
man
um
fake tech greater the feeling
they enrich my life
everything i bite stays with me a long
time
as long as i like and it's really no
problem
to get rid of chocolate peanuts or
spinach
because there are many techniques
something
what is this from this feels like i'm
like just like a monologue you can
audition with or something
oh i have something i want to show you
wow the application of d fake is
phenomenal here i'm a big fan of d fake
videos
i was really in support of what collider
did with transitioning
they haven't even really done that many
deep fake videos
no that's what we gotta do is deep fake
and for your considerations
yeah no i'm a big fan of this kind of
work i often find myself just binge
watching this kind of stuff i've shared
a few videos on the community page
of our channel before and this was great
and i've said it before because like
many months ago i believe
six months ago the video i did with uh
my buddy aaron you know i was like
willem dafoe's always seemed like an
obvious choice to play the joker and
that's kind of why
i've been like i don't know if i really
want him to play the jokers it just
seems so obvious but when i
was looking at this uh i was kind of
showering
the other day i was kind of showering i
had a half shower all the time out of a
fully showered kind of shower
the kind of showers were one toe in the
other toe out you know what i mean john
bing bada boom ba zing toe showers
thinking about the dark knight returns
maybe really cool if they made a live
action movie
that's like really heavily based on the
dark knight returns
and that way you could get a fresh take
on the another fresh take on the joker
and you took that portrayal of him of
someone who
is under the guise of oh i'm i'm healed
now i'm no longer a psychopath but
batman really knows something's up with
him it did hit me then who could play
him
willem dafoe that would be the perfect
version
for willem dafoe to play mwah mottabala
is not a real italian word
are you close to this solid copyright
today very beautiful
solid commentary for you rejects out
there yeah it's funny i felt the exact
same way about willem dafoe over time
it's like it's so on the nose that i'm
often not excited by the concept just
because i know he could do it but seeing
something like this and i thought what
was so choice about it is uh you went
for a
clip that isn't obvious either you know
you could have picked something from
hell spider-man if you wanted to yeah
but instead yeah going with something
that's a little more character-oriented
that could really
showcase what he could bring to the role
i feel like in the front of your mind
you think oh yeah willem dafoe he's got
a crazy look and he can get crazy with
his behavior and mannerisms so
obviously the joker but one of the most
magical things about any great joker
performance i feel like is what comes
from underneath what character notes
come up that are personal to that actor
and yeah if you're talking about you
know a dark knight returns
type of story that gives the joker
something extra psychological to play
and to have fun with from the actor's
perspective
like that yeah it would have to be the
right joker i wouldn't want willem dafoe
to just play
any joker and i would want him to have
like his own
look i would want him to make the makeup
his own but just seeing this
it really did click a lot better than
it's ever clicked in my head yeah i
would actually be down for this now if
you got you know if you told me that
matt reeves idea was to bring him in for
part three
or something like that i would be down
or even just his own other batman
yeah i wouldn't want it to be associated
with the young batman no i feel i i
don't think it will work
i think it'd have to be like wilm the
foe even when you deep fake some of this
makeup on him to make it look more
natural it's clearly an older joker he's
older than joaquin phoenix it makes more
sense if you did
the old man batman and you had william
defoe in there i'll fight you john
i fight you it's okay i take the
statement back i've
i see how dumb i was because yeah you
would have never wanted you to say
i i was so stupid all the videos we've
done together
and as much as fans clamor
at the prospect of willem
dafoe playing the joker there's
something that people
are constantly forgetting of
why it will not work why
it cannot happen here it is
john can you guess what that is um it's
because he's got beef with christian
harlem
no it's because he's already a marvel no
no it's i don't know he's already a dc
there you go he's already a dc he
mentored
aquaman as oh his name is
hold on give me like four minutes what's
his name
grit come on man grimace everyone thinks
you're way more knowledgeable
zordo i
actually weirdly see why you're going
there
it's volca volco there you go anton
volkov
uh yeah volco but then again
they are doing their flash movie which
will open up the you know the
multiverses
with flashpoint of oh you know batman's
actually thomas wayne the joker ended up
being
uh martha wayne having that quality
there you could have an elseworlds
version
maybe where matt reeves batman is and
then have willem dafoe
as the joker in there all right i'll
take you one step further
elseworlds but where willem dafoe is
both the joker
and batman and commissioner gordon
this is everyone's willing to felt do it
like the polar express
i don't like that no
[Laughter]
shoot for the stars well all right guys
would you want willem dafoe to play the
joker and matt reeves version
i know no matter what i say will be like
yeah please
wrong subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell one more
shout out to muhammad x akraf
last but not least
i want to shout out my man jason dolan
because if there's anyone in my
life who i can associate to be a willem
defoe type
it's definitely jason dolan you know why
because he comes across creepy at first
then you get to know him and you're like
you're not all that creepy this guy
seems sweet all things considered
you're actually an all-right guy gentle
even but then he could have this quality
to him too you're like
are you a sinister mofo or are you
someone who could actually be
a good friend and all things considered
i consider him a pretty great friend of
mine now but do i trust him
not when i'm around him in person yeah
definitely not in person because he's a
creeper
he stands way too close and he looks at
you he smiles a lot and he gets
in your face after that one birthday
party i found him watching me from my
closet long after everyone had gone home
he shot me on a talk show
son of a [ __ ] dude he kidnapped me and
then tried to take over my career as a
talk
show host
film references he ruined your shout out
i ruined the shout out for you
i'm sorry jason i'm sorry is going so
good
i will advertise you on any tech you
want a [ __ ] as
[Music]
penance
[Music]
you